[Musique]
merci allez grilla est une école de
samba installée à Tours qui réunit une
bande de joyaux danseurs musiciens pour
célébrer le carnaval de Rio toute
l'année
cette association fondée en 1998 apporte
un peu de brésilité autour en jour et
tout ranger avec près de 50 membres qui
répètent sans relâche
[Musique]
tenez-vous prêt à enflammer votre salon
au rythme des champs percussions et
instruments traditionnels brésiliens
[Musique]
bonjour
je pense qu'il a rien compris à ce que
Nathalie
[Musique]
bravo comme on dit marin du lion dans la
vidéo sur le marché toi tu es un des
fondateurs de l'association exact
alors pour commencer faut piétiner sur
place comme ça 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 une
fois que tu as bien chauffé ça tu vas le
mettre devant ton pied un
après tu mets un peu de grâce en faisant
avec le talon par exemple et du coup
après on accélère
merci mec merci
salut Camille salut Léo
comment s'appelle l'instrument déjà
alors ça c'est une Caixa ce qui a joué
c'est très simple
[Musique]
toi
rythme brésilien vous m'avez chauffé on
va parler de la sauce comment ça
fonctionne vous jouez quand on comment
ou les carnavals commencent à arriver en
mars avril mai là on commence à avoir
beaucoup de dates puis on a déjà fait
beaucoup de gros carnaval aussi on a
fait le carnaval de Nice on a fait le
carnaval de Cholet plusieurs fois
[Applaudissements]
bon j'ai pas de chapeau mais en tout cas
l'esprit est quoi